bonjour roberto duo vannini merci
beaucoup d'être en direct avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france où on a vu un
on parle de l'italie qui oblige ces
soignants à se faire vacciner parce que
cette question avait fait débat en
france et pas forcément accepter ce que
est ce que ça allait en italien ce que
le personnel soignant si les plier à
cette règle
ils vont être obligés de s'y plier
il faut dire que la campagne vaccinale
italie était quelqu'un chronique
pascal différence de la france chaque
région décide qui passionnait priorité
et pour ce qui concerne les personnels
médical on l exemple on a une
vaccination très rapide pour le
personnel hospitalier mais beaucoup
moins pour les médecins libéraux
donc ça ça commençait déjà à la médecine
à deux vitesses
et après il ya les corps des métiers
qu'ils ont fait du lobbying donc d'un
certain région par exemple la vacciner
d'abord les juges dans d autres les
enseignants et pour ce qui est le corps
médical aussi là un débat concernant les
types de vaccins novare et ses lois
parce qu'on peut pas décider le bac
c'est cool en france d'ailleurs les pays
on peut dire actuellement c'est les
états unis et aussi sur les doses des
rappels il y un cafouillage donc il ya
des personnes qui l'ont de la première
d'ordre mais français parce qu'il faut
les faire une première dose pour tout le
monde plutôt qu'un deuxième dose donc
forcément les corps médical c'est les
interpelle et c'est que je trouve triste
c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est la politique
qui donnait des réponses à la révision
médical et ça c'est vraiment un problème
actuellement l'italie et c'est pour ça
qu'on a pas 1 1 10 et 1 5% dès la
campagne vaccinale pour les personnes
enseignants soignants
malgré que la majorité des tués il
adhère mais c'est vrai que ça crée des
plus en plus des questions à ça qu'il
faut faire il par ailleurs aussi escale
à la strat giques à une italie a été
beaucoup
et pourquoi finalement gouvernement a
tranché il a
il a décidé de cette obligation il y
avait beaucoup de cas dans la communauté
soignante italienne de contamination y
amenant d'autres cas mais on peut dire
qu'il y avait des cas classés dans les
sas qu'il y avait et italiens allait des
maisons médicales s'il voulait où il ya
plusieurs à eau des petits hôpitaux et
parfois il y avait des grands nombres de
personnes qui n'étaient pas vaccinés mal
dans la salle d'une même communauté
médicale et donc pour pas donner libre
décision
on les voyait la vaccination mais non il
faut voir parce qu'après c'est ken
décret des lois et l'italie il a eu
beaucoup de polémiques dans les années
passent et que moi j'étais encore en
phase concernant la politique vaccinale
l'obligation de bach scène est par
ailleurs les gens ils chirac font la
constitution ne peut pas être obligés
d'être vacciné donc il est même les
communique avec un appel novak ce qui a
aussi des représentants politiques
moment avec la ligue qui minent unis par
contre les cires aligné sur la politique
vaccinale donc il ya un mélange des
politiques et des synthés qui finalement
où je trouve c'est plutôt la politique
qui donne des réponses plutôt classe nt
alors qu'il faut les données dépenses
médicales il est aussi c'est immonde
départ du corps médical que l'accord
dans une phase d où les vaccins et
incarné une phase expérimentale s'est
pas complètement on sait pas vraiment où
on est comme les vaccins nagy est ce
qu'il y a le même problème qu'en france
c'est à dire pas assez de vaccins
finalement non plus pour pouvoir
atteindre les objectifs y compris dans
la communauté des soignants oui les deux
par ailleurs moi j'ai alors que je t'ai
pas du tout opposé à me faire vacciner
je suis encore vaccinés et après il ya
aussi des programmes du problème de la
programmation parce que les gens ici on
appelait les jours où ils avaient pour
les landais mène donc a priori des
applications donc par exemple de l'art
mardi où j'habite on a dû changer les
serveurs pour s'enregistrer pour fixer
les rendez vous pour les bacs scène donc
il ya eu pas mal de quoi qu'ils font qui
est encore aujourd'hui on a des millions
des vaccinés retard par rapport au
planning prévu par par l'état et dont le
personnel soignant aussi jeudi il ya un
moment c'était le médecin de famille qui
sont créés au scandale du fait qu'ils
arrivent à signer que les gens l'hôpital
et pas que le personnel soignant
on a aussi vacciner les administratifs
alors que les métiers du terrain''
n'étaient pas vaccinés donc oui c'est
c'est sûr qu' il n'y a pas eu une
véritable stratégie et ça aussi je pense
qu'il ya d'un côté en effet que les
corps médical il a commencé à sentir on
peut détacher de cette campagne massive
vaccinale
on n'a pas été les premiers en première
ligne mais moi qui fut directeur ça me
tarde à ma clinique va les proposer les
d35 pour vacciner mais c'était
impossible c'était tout gérer dalle
public et tout directeur administratif
merci beaucoup uberto giovannini d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin depuis
milan en italie je le rappelle vous êtes
médecin chirurgien